all right to Japan now where the
controversial release of treated
radioactive water from the Fukushima
nuclear power plant in Japan has just
begun The Dumping in the Pacific Ocean
comes 12 years after the earthquake and
tsunami which destroyed nuclear reactors
there the Japanese government and the
un's nuclear Watchdog says it's safe to
release more than a million tons of
cooling water if a Japanese fishermen as
well as China and some Pacific island
nations all disagree well Hanukkah
Montgomery is live for us in Fukushima
and Hanukkah talk to us a little bit
about what locals are saying about all
of this there's been a lot of
controversy a lot of build up and now
it's actually happening what is the
reaction
right so as you mentioned the Japanese
government says that this release is
safe and necessary in order to
decommission the plan it's also got in
the go ahead by the iaea the UN nuclear
Watchdog but some locals are condemning
the Japanese government's plan uh you
might be able to see behind me there is
a protest going on at the moment where
locals have gathered to State why they
disagree with Japan's plan we also spoke
to a few of them earlier today when they
were staging a protest outside the deity
nuclear power plant they cited how in
2015 the Japanese government agreed that
it would not release treated radioactive
Wastewater into the ocean without first
getting their approval but as we're
seeing today Japan has still gone ahead
with the discharge right and give us a
sense of how this is going to happen in
terms of the process how is this water
actually being released is it happening
slowly is it going to be sort of
expelled all at once how is this being
done
foreign
yes so we're talking about about 1.33
million tons of water and it's going to
be discharged over the course of 30 to
40 years so it's a relatively slow
discharge tepco the plant operator said
that it will begin releasing it
initially at first in smaller portions
and testing it more frequently so in
order to discharge the water topco will
be diluting it with seawater first to
ensure that it meets a 1 40th of Japan's
concentration in terms of safety levels
the water is then pumped into an
undersea tunnel one kilometer off the
shore which is connected to the Pacific
Ocean now Japan looks to release around
000 tons of waste water which is roughly
equivalent to 30 tanks now in this first
discharge which is expected to take over
the course of 17 days about 7 800 metric
tons will be released and according to
test results announced earlier on
Thursday this first discharge contained
around 63 becquerels of a radioactive
isotope per liter now that's below the
World Health organization's standard for
drinking water levels which is around 10
000 veterans per liter all right
Hanukkah Montgomery reporting live there
for us on that very controversial
release of that Wastewater thank you so
much
all right we're going to talk a little
bit more about this with somebody who
really knows the details because he's
read the iaea report that's the nuclear
watch shock agency that sort of looks
over all of this his name is Chung Guang
yay he is a professor at The Institute
of nuclear engineering and system
science and he joins us live now from
Taiwan talk to us a little bit about
this report you've read what we
understand is that the Isotopes have
been cleared from the water there is an
assurance of safety but how do you know
that that really is the case
okay so what we have now uh are reports
from Taco of Japan and iaea according to
the data released by iaea we saw that
the majority of the radioactive
radioactive isotopes have been filtered
out okay the majority but not only water
has only very low level of radioactive
isotopes and Trivium is the only one
that cannot be filtered and so that's
why the Japanese are diluting the uh the
the trading water and then we release
the water into the ocean
according to the data and it should be
all right because all the other
radioactive isotopes are now in a very
very low level and once again by further
dissolution by the ocean water should be
no particular harm to the environment
and to to the health of the general
public but my opinion is
do you think sorry I just want to jump
in there do you think that diluted water
that still contains Isotopes is going to
be enough to reassure the public that
the fish is safe that the water is safe
if it still has what the public uses
being contaminated
yes yeah because the levels of other
radioactive isotopes are so low okay and
so uh it should cause no harm to the
general public but the problem is people
especially our people in Taiwan they are
all concerned if the release water the
release treated water really contain
just the tritium okay so my suggestion
is the Japanese government should invite
More Country to participate
monitoring the water at the discharge
point in the ocean for for for the
treated water so for example Taiwan was
not invited to the iaea team for
analyzing for analyzing the treated
water but at this point because the
water is not being discharged so I think
more countries should be invited through
the discharge point to collect correct
the seawater sample by themselves and so
they can do their own analysis to make
sure that the treated water release into
the ocean are really okay or not
okay so for now according to the report
I'm all right with the treating water
but the real concern should be if this
is also true for the release water in
the ocean at the discharge Point very
quickly let me jump in one one last
question because we're almost out of
time given the fact this is a slow
release that's going to happen over
decades is there the fear that the
accumulation of water with low levels of
Isotopes could allow for the buildup of
Isotopes making the water ultimately
dangerous
no that's not the case for tritium if
there is only tritium tritium has a
although has a very low physical
half-life of 12.3 years but the
biological half-life of tritium in human
body is only two weeks okay so it would
not pose any accumulation effect in the
human body all right we're going to have
to leave it there Chung Guang yeah we
appreciate you joining us from Taiwan
with your expertise thank you